جميعا بتحيه
الاسلام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله جميعا
وبركاته الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على اشرف الخلق
والمرسلين سيدنا محمد وعلى اله ومن سار
على دربه واهتدى بهديه الى يوم الدين
وبعد احبتي في
الله حديث
اليكم اليوم عن مصدر من مصادر الشريعه
الاسلاميه الا وهي السنه
النبويه التي تتعرض اليوم الى الكثير من
الاتهامات والانتقادات
الهدامه
والتشكيك من اعداء هذا
الدين والمصيبه
العظمى عندما ينقلها
ويروج لها بعض المنتسبين لهذا
الدين
ويكون ممن يدعون ايضا ممن يدعون ايضا من
انهم من علماء هذه الامه او من
مشايخها ذلك لما لهذا من اثر
مدمر على مصدر هام من مصادر هذا الدين
خاصه في هذه
الايام عندما تنتقل عبر وسائط التواصل
الاجتماعي او القنوات
التلفزه وهم لا يعلمون حقيقه
الامر فقد يدخل فقد يدخل الشك في نفوس
البعض وقد ينكرها البعض الاخر وهنا تكمل
مصيبه وهذا
الامر لو نظرنا
اليه
لوجدناه هو قديم وحديث في ان الوقت فكان
التاريخ يعيد
نفسه لو
نظرنا بدا هذا الامر عند
الخوارج لانهم فسقوا وكفروا
الصحابه وبالتالي
هؤلاء الصحابه الذين رووا الاحاديث
الكثيره لا يعول على احاديثهم وبالتالي لا
ياخذون بها ثم انتقل بعد ذلك الى
الروافض الذين
قالوا لا حجه الا ما كان عن طريق اهل
البيت
فقط وغير احاديث اهل البيت لا يعول عليها
فاسقط الكثير من السنه ثم ظهرت في في هذه
الايام
جماعه تطلق تطلق على
نفسها
القرانيين لو نظرنا الى هذه
الجماعه لوجدنا انها هي حديثه المنشا
ولكنها قديمه
الفكره زعيمهم في هذه الايام هو الدكتور
احمد صبحي
منصور دكتور
في جامعه
الازهر للاسف جامعه الازهر التي تخرج
رجالات الدين لجميع العالم
الاسلامي يرى البعض انها تخرج من يحملون
بعض لواء افكار
الغرب
ثم ظهرت جماعه
جديده الا وهي
التنويريين ثم من ريب ظهرت جماعه حديثه
اكثر
التكوين التكوين وعلى راسهم يوسف زيدان
واسامه البحيري
وغيرهم كل
هدفهم من هذا عدم
الاعتراف بمصدر وحجيه
السنه حتى وصل الامر الى بعض احكام القران
وهذا ما نخشاه
في مثل بيقول اول الرقص
حنجله بدا الامر بعدم الاعتراف ببعض
السنه ثم الى انكارها ثم الى تاويل بعض
ايات القران الكريم على غير محمل
معناها
لذلك عندما اقول
اليوم بعض
هؤلاء يقولون عن
الخمر
حلال وعن الربا حلال وهذا موجود عبر وسائط
التواصل
مدعين بان الخمر
حلال
الخمر ليس حرام انما الحرام فيه الاذكار
انظروا الى قلب المعنى تغيير المعنى والتح
الخمر ليس بحرام الحرام فيه
الاسكار وهم لا
يعلمون ان الخمر
حرام والعله في التحريم الاذكار كيف تغيير
المعنى فيقول البعض يا اخي اذا انت بتشرب
ولم تصل الى درجه الاذكار فهذا حلال ليس
بحرام لم يعلموا او يعلموا ويريدون ان
يطمسوا حديث الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم ما
اسكر كثيره فقليله حرام فالحد القليل منه
والكثير على حد سواء خلينا نشوف الربا
الربا مصيبه من مصائب
المجتمعات
لذلك ماذا قالوا عن الربا اذا كان الله
سبحانه وتعالى بين في القران الكريم بصريح
العباره واحل الله البيعه وحرم
الربا ثم ياتي البعض ويقول
الربا الموجود في البنوك ليس ربا انما هو
من باب المعاملات الماليه والمعاملات
الاقتصاديه وهذا يختلف عن الربا الذي كان
في الجاهليه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
يقول ان الذين كفروا ينفقون
اموالهم ليصدوا عن سبيل الله فسينفقونها
ثم تكون عليهم
حسره ثم يغلبون والذين كفروا الى جهنم
يحشرون ويقول الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم
وهو الص صادق المصدوق ويخبرنا عن ان ما
يحدث الان من نكران وجحود للسنه انه سياتي
في المستقبل قال رسول الله قال رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم يوشك
رجل يوشك رجل متكئا على
اريكته يحدث بحديث عني فيقول بيننا وبينكم
كتاب الله الله اين اين السنه
رمسها اذا
نظرنا
احبتي في مصادر التشريع الاسلامي او مصادر
الدين
الاسلامي
نجدها تنقسم الى قسمين كما قسمها
العلماء القسم الاول بسموها المصادر
الاصليه وهناك مصادر اخ تسمى مصادر تبعيه
فالمصادر
الاصليه هي الكتاب والسنه والاجماع
والقياس
واعتبروا ان اهم مصدرين منهما الكتاب
والسنه
ذلك لان الكتاب
والسنه كلاهما وحي من
الله لاختلاف بينه هما القران المصدر
الاول وهو وحي
متلو والمصدر الثاني السنه النبويه وهي
وحي ايضا من الله ولكنه وحي غير
مكلوم اذا نظرنا الى ايات الله سبحانه
وتعالى لتؤكد هذا المعنى الم يقل الله
سبحانه وتعالى
في سوره الكهف في ايه 110 يقول قل انما
انا بشر
مثلكم يوحى الي انما الهكم اله واحد انما
ان بشر مثلكم طب وين الفرق يوحى اليه اذا
هو ما ياتيه ياتيه من الوحي من الله
سبحانه وتعالى وهناك ايات اخرى الم يقن
الله سبحانه وتعالى في سوره النجم والنجم
اذا
هوى ما ضل صاحبكم وما غوى وما ينطق عن
الهوى ان هو الا وحي يوحى اذا ما يقوم به
الرسول هو وحي من عند الله سبحانه
وتعال ناتي الان
للسنه
السنه المتعارف عليها عندنا ورد ذكرها في
القران الكريم ست في 16 ع
موضعا
ولكنها لم يكن المقصود بها السنه التي نحن
الان
بصددها
السنه اللفظ القراني الذي جاء في القران
ليعبر عن السنه كلمه هي كلمه
الحكمه وليست بكلمه السنه انما المقصود
بالحكمه
والدليل قول الله سب سبحانه وتعالى في
اكثر من موضع يقول الله سبحانه
وتعالى هو الذي بعث في الاميين رسولا منهم
يتلو عليهم
اياته
ويزكيهم
ويعلمهم الكتاب والحكمه وان كانوا من قبل
لفي ضلال مبين في سوره الجمعه الايه
الثانيه وقال ايضا
كما ارسلنا فيكم رسولا منكم يتلو عليكم
اياتنا ويزكيكم ويعلمكم الكتاب والحكمه
ويعلمكم ما لم تكونوا
تعلمون البقره
151 وقال تعالى مخاطبا امهات المؤمنين
واذكرن ما يتلى في بيوتكن من ايات الله
والحكمه ان الله كان لطيفا خبيرا
والحكمه كما قال علماء التفسير هي عباره
عن السنه والكتاب هو القران الكريم وصدق
قول الحبيب المصطفى عندما قال الا اني
اوتيت الكتابه
ومثله
معه ومن هنا فرض الله سبحانه وتعالى
طاعته كما فرض طاعه رسوله
وذلك من خلال ايات كثر في القران تثبت
حجتها
ودلالتها وما ساذكر عليكم هو على سبيل
الذكر لا على سبيل الحصر قال الله سبحانه
سبحانه وتعالى في سوره الحشر وما اتاكم
الرسول
فخذوه وما نهاكم عنه فانتهوا الايه
سبعه وقوله تعالى اطيعوا الله والرسول
لعلكم ترحمون في ال عمران
132 وقوله تعالى قل اطيعوا الله والرسول
فان تولوا فان الله لا يحب الكافرين ال
عمران الايه
32 وقال ايضا ومن يطع
الرسول فقد اطاع الله في سوره النساء فطاع
الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم من طاعه الله
طاعه الله واجبه فاعه الرسول ايضا هي
واجبه يا ايها الذين امنوا اطيعوا الله
واطيعوا الرسول واولي الامر
منكم في
الكثير بيعتقد انه واولي الامر منكم هي
طاعتهم كاعه الله ورسوله لا لاحظوا سياق
الايه الكريمه واطيعوا الله
ثم قال واطيعوا الرسول اذا طاعه الله
مطلقه وطاعه الرسول مطلقه ولم يقل واطيعوا
اولي الامر منكم قال واولي الامر منكم
الواو حرف
عطف فطاع اولياء الامور معطوفه على طاعه
الله ورسوله ولذلك قالوا لا طاعه لا طاعه
لمخلوق
في معصيه الخالق فاول ياء الامر ان كانت
اوامرهم ضمن طاعه الله وطاعه الرسول فلهم
الطاعه
علينا كما ان الله سبحانه
وتعالى اوجب على المؤمنين
طاعته طاعه رسوله والالتزام بامره ولا
يجوز للمؤمن ان يخرج عن ذلك فقد قال
سبحانه وتعالى
وما كان لمؤمن ولا مؤمنه اذا قضى الله
ورسوله امرا ان يكون لهم الخيره من
امرهم
كما
وتحكيم رسول الله رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم فيما شجر بينهم هو من كمال
الطمانينه لما يقضي
به واجب وهو على من علامات الايمان الم
يقل الله سبحانه وتعالى فلا وربك لا
يؤمنون حتى يحكموك فيما شجر بينهم ثم لا
يجدوا في انفسهم حرجا مما قضيت ويسلم
تسليما من خلال هذه المقدمه البسيطه فما
هي
السنه وما هي
اهميتها وما هي مكانتها من القران الكريم
ولماذا اعداء
الاسلام قديما وحديثا يريدون التشكيك
والطعن فيها وبتالي الى الغائها والاكتفاء
بالقران وقد صدق من
قال منل السنه عطل القران اذ ان القران
الكريم بدون السنه اصبح رموز لا يمكن
لكثير من احكامه من ان تنفذ او ان
تطبق معنى
السنه اذا اردنا بشكل سريع يختلف عندما
نقول هذا الموضوع لطلبه العلم فطلبه العلم
نقول لهم يختلف تعريف السنه حسب الغرض
المنشود من ورائه وعند من فعندما نقول
علماء
الاصول فيعرفون السنه على غير ما يقوم به
الفقهاء الفقيه و وغير ما يقوم به المحدث
فعند علماء الاصول اي هم اصول الفقه
فيقول
الغرض من السنه البحث عن المصدر الذي ثبت
به الحكم الشرعي
كدليل وهو حكم تكليفي من الاحكام
الفقهيه بمعنى هي المصدر الثاني من مصادر
التشريع التي يحكم بها على
التكليف
مثال عندما اقول صوم يوم الاثنين والخميس
ويوم عرفه لغير الحاج والايام البيض ما
حكمها بتقول لي سنه يعني ثبت هذا الحكم
بمدريه السنه كدليل اذا هم بيهمهم
الدليل بينما اذا
نظرنا الى تعريف
الفقهاء الغرض منه البحث في السنه هو عن
حكم الشرع على افعال العباد
بمعنى انت بتروح عند الفقيه بتقول له فعلت
كذا وكذا وكذا ما حكم ما فعلت بقول لك سني
ما حكم كذا بقول لك فرض ما حكم كذا بقول
لك واجب هل السنه تاتي بالفرض نعم
السنه تاتي بالاحكام الفقهيه
الخمسه مباح فرض مندوب حرام مكروه حسب
النص وحسب دلاله النص الذي جاء في السنه
كدليل على هذا
الامر اذا لما ققول العلماء الفقه هذا
السنه بمعنى ما
يثاب فاعله ولا يعاقب
تاركه بينما لما انا بجي بقول هذا فرض
ثبت بالسنه هنا اختلف غير السنه عند
الفقهاء الفقهاء لما بقولوا هذا امر سنه
والبعض بقول عن السنه هي
مندوب ايش يعني يعني ما يثاب فاعله ولا
يعاقب تاركه بينما عند اصحاب الحديث
لاحظوا الموضوع دقيق لانه حسب الغرض
المقصود من عند العلماء زي
الطب الطب مش كله واحد في عندك طب
طبيب
بيدرس اعصاب ودماغ هذا الغرض منه الاعصاب
والدماغ في ناس بختص في القلب في ناس بختص
بالصدريه في ناس بختص بالعظام كله له غرضه
ومجاله ولكن الاطار العام كله طب والسنه
كذلك اطارها العام واحد ولكن الغرض
العلماء الذين يشتغلون بها كل له غرض معين
من داخل
لاحظوا عند علماء الحديث والمحدثين بقولوا
هو كل ما اضيف الى النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم من قول او فعل او تقرير او
صفه الان الحديث بشتغلوا بالحديث
بقولوا من اول يوم من
بعثته الى
وفاته
المحدثين بقولوا لا هو من من اول يوم من
حياته الى وفاته فنضيف عليها او صفه خلقيه
او خلقيه من اول يوم من حياته الى وفاته
طب شو الاختلاف وشو
الاضافه عندما نزل على رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم الوحي من هذه اللحظه ما يصدر
عنه من قول او فعل او تقرير يبنى عليه حكم
شرعي
اما ما كان قبل البعثه قبل ان يكون نبيا
وقبل نزول الوحي عليه هي من باب السيره
ولذلك
بنقول تجارته لخديجه رعايته للغنم حاسه شق
الصدر وغيرها وغيرها هذه سيره عن الرسول
صل الله عليه وسلم ولكنه عندما بعث وانزل
عليه الوحي فاصبح ما يصدر عنه من قول او
فعل او تقرير مبني عليه حكم شرعي يجب
علينا ان نلتزم به حسب
دلالته
لذلك السنه
جاءت باحاديث
كثيره قول فعل تقرير من هنا العلماء
قسموا السنه الى ثلاثه اقسام سنه قول
سنه فعليه وسنه
تقريريه وكل وحده لها
دلاله اذا نظرنا الى السنه
القوليه جميع ما قاله رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم في مختلف المناسبات والمجالات
في
الحياه الفعليه افعاله التي صدرت عنه
التقريريه كل ما اقره الر رسول وسلم سواء
كان
بالتصريح او بالسكوت لذلك بقول علماء عننا
التقرير اما
انون تصريحي او سكوتي
مثال الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم قدم
له مع الصحابه
الضب والضب مشهور في جزيره العرب كثيرا
وقد قدموا لطلاب في مناسبه من المناسبات
كانوا واضعين الضب والضب هو حيوان صحراوي
من
الزواحف فلما وضعوا وضعوه امام الحبيب
المصطفى صلى الله عل عل وسلم قال ما هذا
قالوا يا رسول الله الضب قال ابعدوه
عني فقال له الصحابه يا رسول الله اوحرام
هو
قال لا ولكن تعافه نفسي وفي روايه ليس من
طعام اهلي اذا هنا صرح اذا في عنا تقرير
ولكنه تصريحي
صرح في عننا التقرير
السكوتي رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
لا يصلين احدكم العصر الا في بني
قريضه لا يصلي
احدكم العصر الا في بني قريض ما ان انتهى
من حديثه بعض الصحابه قام وصل
العصر وقسم منهم
اخر صلاه العصر الى ان وصلوا الى
مني لم ينكر رسول الله صل الله عليه وسلم
على هؤلاء لماذا قاموا وصلوا اذا هم هو
اقر على
ذلك من كل ذلك نقول اذا السنه بهذه
المجالات
الثلاث هي عباره
عن قول فعل
تقرير اذا نظرنا الان الى هذه السنه
التقريريه والقوليه
والفعليه ما
مكانتها في القران الكريم مكانتها في
القران الكريم العلماء بيقولوا
لها منزل ومكانه عظيمه
واحد تاتي
السنه
مثبته
وموافقه لحكم ورد في القران الكريم
يعني ايه بتجيب حكم بتيجي السنه وبتاكد
وبتوافق هذا الحكم وهذا كثير في القران
الكريم اذا هي موافقه ومثبته لحكم ورد في
القران الكريم يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى
واقيم الصلاه واتوا الزكاه ان الصلاه كانت
على المؤمنين كتابا موقوتا
طيب يا الجماعه اللي انتم قاعدين بتقولوا
السنه لا تعتبر دليلا او حجه ولا مصدرا من
مصادر هذا الدين بالله عليكم افيدونا بدنا
نصلي الله سبحانه وتعالى قال واقيموا
الصلاه
طيب اذا نظرنا الى هذه
الايه كم
نصلي ما عدد الصوات ما عدد الركعات ركعه
كل
صلاه متى نصلي اوقات الصلاه وان كان في
بعض القران الكريم شيء بسيط منها لكن في
مجملها لم
تاتي لاحظوا لاحظوا اقيموا الصلاه واتوا
الزكاه اجا القران اجا حديث الرسول بيقول
بني الاسلام على خمس شهاده ان لا اله الا
الله وان محمدا رسول الله اقام الصلاه
ايتاء الزكاه صوم رمضان وحج والبيت اذا
جاءت السنه واكدت فرضيه الصلاه والصوم
والزكاه وال
الحج
ايضا الله سبحانه وتعالى بقول في القران
الكريم وكذلك اخذ ربك اذا اخذ القرى وهي
ظالمه ان اخذه اليم شديد في سوره هود جاء
حديث الرسول صلى عليه وسلم عن ابي موسى
الاشعري قال قال رسول عليه وسلم ان الله
ليملي
للظالم فاذا
اخذه لم يفلته تؤكد على ان الظالم الله
سبحانه وتعالى ياخذه عن بكره
ابي ولذلك الله سبحانه وتعالى قال ايضا
يمحق الله الربا ويربي الصدقات يا ايها
الذين امنوا يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا
الله وذروا ما بقي من الربا فان لم تفعلوا
فاذنوا بحرب من الله ورسوله كل
هذه جاءت احاديث الرسول
وسلم اجتنبوا السبع الموبقات بتاكد على
حكم تحريم الربا اجتنبوا السبع
الموبقات الشرك بالله والسحر وقتل النفس
التي حرم الله الا بالحق واكل الربا اذا
السنه تاتي مؤكده وفي حديث اخر لعن الله
اكل الربا
وموكله وكاتبه وشاهد ديه وقال هم
سواء منزله اخرى السنه تاتي موضحه كما قلت
قبل قليل تاتي
موضحه
ومبينه وشارحه ومفسره لما جاء في القران
الكريم من حكم
مجملا اذا نظرنا الى احكام القران الكريم
لوجدناها على صنفين الصنف الاول
احكام تف تفصيليه
مفصله
واحكام اجماليه
مجمله الاحكام التفصيليه التي وردت في
القران ما علينا الا ان ناخذها ونقوم على
تطبيقها مثل المحرمات من
النساء واضحه جدا
ثم تعالوا خلينا نشوف ايات المواريث
يوصيكم الله في
اولادكم دقيقه وموضحه اذا مفصله
ولكن في بعض الاحكام
القرانيه جاءت مجمله دون تفسير ولا بيان
ولذلك جاءت السنه
النبويه تفسر
وتبين ما نزل من القران الكريم
مجملا الصلاه زي ما قلت
والصوم كيف نعرف مبطلات الصلاه عدد ركعات
الصلاه متى نصلي شروط صحه الصلاه كل هذه
الامور القران الكريم لم يتحدث عنها بل
الذي تحدثت عنها السنه النبويه قام الرسول
صل الله عليه وسلم وصلى امام الصحابه
الكرام وبعد ان انتهى من صلاته قال لهم
صلوا كما رايتموني
اصلي في
الحج كان جبريل يعلمه مناسك الحج من سكن
من سكن والصحابه يؤدون مناسك الحج من
ورائه وبعد ان انتهى قال لتاخذ عني
مناسككم كذلك
الزكاه الزكاه امرنا الله سبحانه وتعالى
بالزكاه طب ما هي انصبه الزكاه ما هي
الاموال التي تجب فيها الزكاه يقول الرسول
صلى عليه وسلم فيما سقت السماء العشر
وفي اشياء كثيره لولا وجود السنه لما
عرفنا كيف نطبق هذه الاحكام التي جاءت في
القران الكريم ولذلك قال احد العلماء ان
حاجه السنه الى القران اكثر من حاجه السنه
اكثر من حاجه القران الى السنه لانها لولا
السنه لما استطعنا ان نقوم على اقامه حكم
واحد من الاحكام التي جاءت
مجمله
ايضا منزله اخرى غير انها تاتي قلنا مثبت
مثبته وموافقه ومفسره
ومبينه تاتي السنه ايضا ناسخه لحكم ورد في
القران وهذا لا اريد ان ادخل في موضوع
النسخ في القران واراء العلماء فيه فالسنه
الصحيحه تنسخ بعض ما جاء بالقران الكريم
مثال الله سبحانه وتعالى طبعا لماذا لاننا
قلنا ان القران وحي والسنه وحي فكلاهما من
عند الله والله سبحانه وتعالى يثبت ما
يشاء وينسخ ما
يشاء قال الله سبحانه وتعالى كتب عليكم
اذا حضر احدكم الموت ان ترك خيرا الوصيه
للوالدين والاقربين
اذا الايه تجيز وتبيح الوصيه للوالدين
والاقربين
جاء حديث الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم فقال
لا
وصيه
لوارث اذا نظرنا الى هذا الحديث نجد انه
نسخ بعض حكم جاء في الايه الكريمه
فيقول ان الله فيقول الرسول وسلم ان الله
قد اعطى كل ذي حق حقه فلا وصيه لوارث في
روايه الاخرى فجاء الحديث فدل على نسخ
الوالدين من
الوصيه فكل من
يرث فكل من يرث لا تجوز له
الوصيه وابقت الوصيه للاقربين الذين
لا يرثون اذا
الوالدين يرثوا اذا لا وصيه لهم الاقربين
الذين لا يرثون نصيبا مفروضا لو واحد وصل
لهم الوصيه جائزه اما ان يجمع الانسان ما
بين النصيب المفروض وما بين الوصيه فهذا
مخالف مخالف للشرع لقول الحبيب المصطفى
صلى الله علسلم لا وصيه
لوارث امر اخر منزله اخرى السنه
تاتي باحكام
جديده
مستقله ليست في القران يعني بمعنى اخر لم
يرد الحكم في القران بينما استقلت السنه
بها فهي اذا واجبه الاتباع لانها وحي من
الله والامثله على
ذلك المحرمات من النساء قلنا قبل قليل
حرمت عليكم امهاتكم وبناتكم واخواتكم
وعماتكم وخالاتكم وبنات الاخي الى اخر
الايه ان تقول وان تجمعوا بين الاختين الا
ما قد سلف طيب ممتاز هي المحرمات اجاك
واحد اجا للشيخ حسن وقال له يا شيخ حسن
انا
متزوج وبدي
اتزوج عمه زوجتي او خاله
زوجتي
بصير والله الشيخ حسن دوب في القران
الكريم ق والله ما شفتلك نص ما في نص بحرم
الجمع الزوجه مع عمت او خلام
صحيح ولكن التحريم هنا وانم وان لم في
القران فقد جاء
بالسنه السنه جاءت وشرعت وقالت لا تنكح
المراه على عمتها ولا على خالتها انكم ان
فعلتم ذلك قطعتم ارحامكم
طيب امر
ثاني كثير من الشباب او الرجال بتلاقيه من
باب الزينه بروح حط لي خاتم ذهب او لما
يتزوج في عندكم زواج هون لما بتزوج بروح
بجيب دبلتين خاتمين ذهب
وبيلبس طيب الشيخ حسن شافه
لابسه رح يقول له
يا اخي الفاضل الذهب واتخذتم الذهب للذكور
حرام بيجي بقول له يا والله دورت في
القران الكريم لا يوجد ما يحرم ذلك والله
كلامه صحيح نعم لا يوجد في القران ما يحرم
لبس الذهب للذكور او لبس الحرير ولذلك قام
الرسول صلى عليه وسلم واخذ قطعه من الذهب
في يده اليمنى وقطعه من الحرير في يده
اليسرى وقال هذان حرام على ذكور
امتي حل
لنسائها وطبعا قال حرام على ذكور بدي اعلق
شوي على كلمه ذكور لانه في اللغه العربيه
وفي المصطلح في فرق بين الرجل
والذكر هلا بتاخذ زوجتك على المستشفى تلد
بقوللك مبروك يا شيخ اسامه اجاك ولد اجاك
بنت
اجاك ذكر اذا هو
جنس لذلك في
التحريم قال على
ذكور في
القوامه قوامه الرجل على المراه قال
الرجال قوامون على النساء لانه العلاقه
بتقول كل رجل ذكر وليس كل ذكر رجل لانه
والله مع احترام من الجميع في ذكور في
ذكور هبل ومجانين ومعتوه ولا يصح لقوام
لذلك قال الرجال قوامون على
النساء امر امر
اخر
السنه تاتي قلنا بحكم
جديد مثل قلنا تحريم لبس الذهب
والفضه
تحريم لحم اكل الحمر الاهليه
هلا الحمير اعزكم الله تنقسم الى قسمين
عننا الحمر الوحشيه بسموها الزيبرا
بالانجليزي وفي عننا الحمير اللي بتعيش
بين
الاهالي في السنه الخامسه للهجره قال عليه
الصلاه والسلام حرمت عليكم اكل لحم الحمر
الاهليه ونكاح المتعه فنكاح المتعه لو
وجدنا في القران ما في نص قراني بحربه ال
اللي حرمته السنه واللي حرم اكل لحم الحمر
الاهليه ايضا السنه وكذلك حرمت من الكواسر
والجوارح الكواسر هي ما تكسر رقبه
فريستها من رقبتها
بفكيها والجوارح هي ما تجرح الفريسه
بمخالبها لذلك قال حرم عليكم كل ذ مخلب من
الطير وكل ذ ناب من السباع
امر اخر من مكانه
السنه السنه تاتي
مخصصه لعموم
القران وتاتي ايضا
مقيده لما جاء في القران الكريم مطلقا
يعني ان شاء الله ما اكون الالفاظ شوي
صعبه الان خلينا نشوف
كلمه السنه تاتي مخصصه
لما جاء في القران الكريم عاما لعموم
القران مثل يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى في
سوره المائده حرمت عليكم الميته والدم
ولحم الخنزير الى اخر الايه فكل ميته حرام
هيك
الاصل عموم وكل ايضا الم والدم وكل دم
حرام هذا ما افته الايه
الايه افادت هذا المعنى شوفوا كيف الان
جاءت السنه وقالت احلت لكم
ميتتان
ودمان اما الميتتان فالسمك والجراد واما
الدمان فالكبد
والطحال المصيبه اني كنت اشوف في بعض
الدول لما اروح اشتري سمك على الكرتونه
طبعا سمك مستورد على الكرتونه بكتب كتبوا
عليه مذبوح على الطريقه
الاسلاميه مذبوح على الطريقه الاسلاميه يا
عمي انتم تقراوا ولا بتقرا ما هو رسول عل
وسلم قال احلت لكم
ميتتان
ودمان السمك والجراد يا سلام اخواننا
اليمنيين بكيف في موسم الجراد وانا كنت
اشوفهم عقبت السعوديه 12 سنه
كانه لما بيجي موسم الجراد بمسكو بيخلع
الراس هيك و بياكله كانه بياكل
فستق هذا هذا اذا انت عندك نفس بق تقدر
تاكله اما انا تعفه نفسي زي ما قال سيدنا
محمد قال انه ليس من من طعام اهله ولكنه
مباح اه مادان مباح خلاص انت بكلوش ماشي
مش مشكله واما الدمان الكبد
والطحال لاحظ يوم عيد عيد الاضحى بتلاقي
الكل فطورهم من المعلاق واولها الكبده اذا
وهو عباره عن دم ولكنه مباح بنص الحديث
الشريف اذا ماذا فعلت السنه السنه جاءت
فخصصت شيء مما جاء في القران الكريم
محرما امر
اخر يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى يوصيكم الله
في اولادكم الذكر مثل حظ
الانثيين عموم الايه بينت التوارث اليس
كذلك في توارث طيب هذا عام يوصيكم الله
الله في
اولادكم طيب خلينا نقول جاءت السنه فخصصت
انه لا يتوارث اهل
ملتين فلا يرث مسلم كافر ولا كافر ك مسلم
بمعنى الاب اذا كان الاب كافرا والا
والابن مسلما او
العكس فلا توارث بينهما او خلينا نقول
شغله ثانيه زي ما بصير هون عندكم في توسان
او في امريكا او في اي ولايه اذا كان
الزوج مسلما والمراه
كتابيه
فهذا
لا اخت لوجود اختلاف المنه فلا يرثها ولا
ترثها هذا في القانون الاسلام في القانون
الوضع نجي ايضا
قلنا تاتي مخصصه لعموم القران
ومقيده لما جاء في القران الكريم مطلقا في
الفاظ جاءت مطلقه بالمثال يتضح الكلام
الله سبحانه وتعالى عندما كما يقول
والسارق والسارقه فاقطعوا ايديهما جزء بما
كسبا نكالا من
الله
الاصليه دلت على امر ملق ايش هو كل واحد
مرق والسارق
والسارقه فكل واحد بسرق بد تقيموا عليه
الحد هيك الاصل في اللفظ القراني فاقطعوا
ايديهما
الان صار في عندي امرين قلنا السارق
والسارقه مهما كان اسمه
سارق فجاء حديث الرسول صلى الله عليه
وسلم
وقال طب صحيح قبل ذلك نقطعها من وين يا
شيخ حسن واحد سرق من وين نقطعله ايده طيب
لو اجيت
سالت
يد اليد بجي بقول ل
واحدك الكلام
واحداني صح واحداني
ودك والله الكلامه صحي لماذا كه هذا لفظ
هذا لفظ يطلق على كل ما ذكروه لانه جاء
كلمه ايديهما مطلقه
لما سرق احد في عهد النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم قالوا يا رسول الله فاقطعوا ايديهما
من وين
اقطعها فبين مكان القطع لانه مسميات اليد
كل واحده لها مسمى ولكن كلها يد فبين ان
مكان القطع يكون من
الرسغ فلولا السنه العمليه لما بينت لما
عرفنا كيف ومن اين تقطع اليد طيب
طب وموضوع والسارق والسارقه ايضا لفظ
مطلق فكل واحد بينطبق انه سرق بمسكه ونطبق
عليه حكم الشريعه الحد جاء ح حديث الرسول
صلى عليه وسلم قال لا تقطع اليد لا تقطع
اليد الا في ربع دينار
فصاعدا ربع دينار مش يعني 25 قرش لا ربع
دينار من الذهب يعني واحد سرق شيء مالهش
قيمه كثير هذا لا يعاقب حدا انما يعاقب
تعزيرا لذلك كل هال
المكانه لهذا
الدين من خلال السنه وبيجوا
كثير كثير ممن هم محسوبين على الاسلام
والمسلمين ولكن عندهم اجندات خارجيه بيجي
بقول لك
السنه لا نعمل بها ونكتفي بالقران الكريم
هذه كلمه باطله اريد اريد بها باطل اراد
ان يعطلوا احكام القران من خلال تعطيل
السنه اللهم اني اسالك ان تعلمنا ما
جاهلنا وان تنفعنا بما علمتنا وزدنا علما
يا الله في الختام اشكركم جميعا على
حضوركم كما والشكر موصول باهله للقائمين
على هذا المسجد واخص بالذكر اخواني امام
المسجد حسن والاخ اسامه واخي الكبير احمد
جابر واخر دعوانا ان الحمد لله رب
العالمين وسلام على المرسلين والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته اذا في حدا عنده اي سؤال تفضل اه
تفضل هلا الا حلو هلا بما انه الاب مسلم
ودائما الابناء
لمن لابوهم بس في في هالبلد هذا لا حسب
احيان بيختاروا هم لانه ممكن تلاقي الاب
مسلم والام والام كتابيه والاولاد لا لانه
اليوم في عندنا موديل جديد اسمه جماعه
اللادينيين هذول موجودين بيجي بحكي لك انه
يا اخي بما انه ال انا شايف انه الدين هو
سبب المشاكل بين الناس كلها وبالتالي انا
لا بدي اكون ولا اتباع ولا دين فانا لا
ديني هلا اذا كان الاب مسلما واولادهم
مسلمين وتوفي الاب على طول بيرث ليش لانه
الم المله واحد حده اذا الاولاد توفوا
والاب والاب موجود الاب يرث لانه في عننا
مله واحده لذلك اهل ملتين لا يتوارث ابدا
تفضل
اه حلو مش بس هيك هو في شروط ثانيه في قبل
ان نقوم بالحد في مجموعه من الشروط اول
شرط ان يكون المال المسروق مملوكا لصاحبه
يعني انا مره جبت سؤال طلابي بالجامعه قلت
لهم ما
حكم انسان سرق مالا فتبين ان المال الذي
سرقه كان
مسروقا فما
الحكم قلنا الانسان الذي سرق هذا المال
لتبين انه مسروق ليس عليه حد القطع لانه
سرق مالا غير مملوك لصاحبه انما مش معناها
انه اذا كان ما لا يقام عليه الحد مع
بقوله مع السلامه لا يقام عليه عقوبه
تعزير والعقوبه التعزيريه هي العقوبه التي
يرتقيها القاضي او الحاكم عليه امر اخر
ذكرت بشغله انت اخر اللي هو لو انسان وجد
محفظه بسياره مت ايده اخذها وراح هل عليه
هل عليه حد لا لانه يجب ان يكون المال اول
شيء مملوكا لصاحبه اثنين ان يكون مخ خبا
في حرز والحرز هو المكان الذي يخب به
المال عاده وهذا يعرف عند العرف والعاده
فالمال السايب شو بقولوا بعلم بعلم بعلم
الحرميه السرقه ولذلك اذا كان المال قد
اخذ من
حرز و وزاد عن النصاب السرقه اللي هو لا
قطعه في ربع دينار فصاع لو كان اقل لا هذا
من شروط اقامه الحب طبعا في شروط ثانيه
ب
[Silence]
‏res
في عمر عب المجاعه
‏cing up
says are
[Silence]
تصديقا لكلام الاخ حسن سؤالك في عام عام
المجاعه او عام
الرماده سيدنا عمر اوقف حد السرقه على من
سرق لكي
ياكل اما في ناس بتسرق عشان تستغني عندها
بيوت ففي فرق فان سرق لكي ياكل لا يقام
عليه الحد انما يقام عليه عقوبه تعزيه
شايف كيف لذلك في في لكل حد مجموعه من
الشروط اذا توفرت هذه الشروط يقام الحد
لانه المقصد ليس اقامه الحد احنا ليس
المقصود هو اقامه العقوبه لا العلماء
بقولوا في عننا قاعده تقول عقوبات هي
موانع قبل الفعل زواجر
بعده
فالاصل شبح العقوبه يكون موجود امام
الانسان قبل ان يقدم
عليها ايوه فان فكر في قيامه بواحده منها
فشبه العقوبه تمنعه فشو بقول هو كل واحد
سرق مسكوه خلينا نجرب حظها فلما ب بيقيموا
عليه الحد بتصير اقامه الحد مانعه له ان
يقام ان يقوم على تكرارها لذلك قالوا
العقوبات هي موانع قبل الفعل هي زواجر
بعدها تفضل
شيخ
فائده فائ الشص
نصل حلو على
اساسان مش حلال
علخل
الشخص جميل
جميل طيب هلا الاصل انت تقر عند وضعك هذا
المال في البنك ان الربا
حرام يجب ان تقر هذا الشيء لانه علمائنا
بقولوا فعل الحرام شيء واستباحه الحرام
شيء اعظم هلا اللي بزني اوكي ماشي اللي ب
اوكي بشرب خمر ولكن ان تقول لي الزنا
والخمر حلال هذه اشد اثما من
فعله الان لما انت انت عقين بانه الربا
حرام وانت بدك تحط مالك في بنك وهذا البنك
الربوي على شان تحافظ على هذا المال من
السرقه وبتاخذ عليه نسبه معينه
فائده بمجرد ان تاخذ انت الفائده هذه ما
ما بتنفع فيها فتقوم على التخلص بها من
خلال اعطاءها للفقراء والمساكين
حكمها لك اجر التخلص منها لك
اجر
طبعا وفيها
[Silence]
‏remember said are
يعني الشيخ اسامه يعني هو لا يعتبر لك
اجرها كاجر الصدقه او الزكاه انما لك اجر
التخلص منها لان الله سبحانه وتعالى ان
الله تعالى طيب لا يقبل الا طيبا هذه
كصدقه اما انت لك اجر التخلص منها
ا
راميو في قه
موجود اه اه يا سي سلامتك وعاف ان شاء
الله ما هو في ربنا
بيقول العلماء اعتمدوا
عفوا العلماء اعتمدوا فان تبتم فلكم رؤوس
اموالكم لا تظلمون ولا تظلمون
الك انت اجر التخلص منها مع قناعتك
واعتقادك الايماني لانه الربا اصلها
حرام عفوا افضل
[Silence]
الحسابات الجاريه مضبوط اه بدل اخذ
الحسابات وخل الحساب انا ما
اخ اذا حصل فيه
فائده فائده انا اتخلص منها واححد عن
مزبوط هو في حسابات تسمى حسابات
جاريه موج حال هذا لعك جاريه
[Silence]
يعطوها المعونه المعونه
ها بس
قرض
اه الفائ
هذ بما انك في بما انك في دوله غير
اسلاميه وهم منتفعين بهذا المبلغ شايف كيف
انت بتاخذه زي ما قال وبتخلص منه ولك اجر
التخلص
الاولى
الاولى الاولى الاولى
عدمه الاولى الاولى عدمه
بالضبط ايوه لهذا لهذا انا بقول انه يعني
المسلم في بلاد الكفر بيعاني
بيعاني الربا الربا الربا هو كل قرض جر
نفع كل قرض جر نفع فهو ربا هلا في عندك
انت ب مدان انتم هون في شيء اسمه خطاب
الاعتماد
وفتح الاعتماد اللي عندهم شركات وعندهم
مصالح كبيره هلا فتح الاعتماد غير خطاب
الاعتماد هلا انت بتروح على الصين او على
اليابان بتستورد اباع قيمتها منا نص مليون
دولار انت النص مليون معك بتروح بتاخذ
النص مليون وبتروح على البنك بتعطيهم النص
مليون بتقول لهم انا بدي اعمل خطاب اعتماد
الشركه المايه هذا المبلغ ف بتعطيهم انت
المبلغ وهم بياخذوا منك كوميشن يعني 100
دول 50 دول اللي هي عماله عموله البنك هي
اتعاب البنك في المراسلات
وانتهى هذا على هيك صيغه حلال وجائز الامر
الثاني فتح الاعتماد انت ما عندك هذا
المبلغ بس انت انسان لك اسمك ومكانتك في
السوق بتروح على البنك وقول له انا بدي ا
اما الي ايوه هو قرض بشكل اخر بيفتحوا لك
بيفتحوا لك الاعتماد شايف من خلال اقتطاع
مبلغ اسمك كفن بداوا هم يحولوه مقابل مبلغ
انت بتدفعه عليه اللي هي ربا في فرق اذا
بين خطاب الاعتماد وفتح الاعتماد الان
القرض اللي انت بتاخذه اما ان يكون قرضه
حسنه واما ان يكون قرضه مقابل
مال فان كان كل قرض جر نفع على المقرض فهو
يعني بتقوللي انا بدي منك 2000 2000 دولار
بجي بقوللك بعطيك 2000 دولار لنهايه الشهر
بعطيني اياهم
موجوده
100% فلوس
انت وما اخذت شيء من البنك وبالتالي انت
ما اخذت ولا مبلغ هون ما في ما فرضوا عليك
اي شيء
الفائز لا من الاصل يعني اذا استطعت انه
بدون فائده بكون احسن
وافضل جزاك الله خير
[Silence]
‏should
الع
[Silence]
الحله
عل
ح
[Silence]
بك
الله
‏sk